all right before we say goodbye I have
one more great St to share on this
Veteran Day this is what I'm
liking the art has always been a source
of healing for veterans including dance
and in Florida a retired veteran
switched out his combat boots for tap
[Music]
shoes that's Knack knack better known as
major Mac he's the founder of the
veterans art center in Tampa Bay we have
him on the line right now watching on
Tampa Bay's M TV what's up major Mac hey
hey hey what's up what's going on in New
York oh man well how long did it take
you to learn how to tap oh it took me
about five weeks Lindsay white my
instructor was my drill sergeant for
five weeks so we did a a tap dance
instruction and for our dance party when
hurricane Kan Ian hit at Fred a stair we
had this tap dancing thing and all of my
board members are like major Mac major
Mac uh can you do a tap dance and I said
yeah anything to bring in people and
create memories and laughter yeah and it
feels good I used to tab when I was a
kid it's fun so this there's a serious
reason behind this though right yeah so
um I retired out of USS St Pete and US
Army cadc command and running in
downtown St Petersburg I had this
Epiphany to start a center for military
veterans First Responders and amilies
and actually this is our 10th year
anniversary as well and so we do mental
health healing and suicide prevention
and we're up to four prevented suicides
right now currently we reached out
around 2, 2500 veterans with our various
programs that we have done and are doing
wow well thank you so much n m I'm
liking your post right now
right and that's actually not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
G2 the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show Believe in your efforts to support
veterans so they're going to be riding
the veterans art center of Tampa Bay a
check for $1,000 what's the
s thank you so much major Mack and thank
you to all our guests it's our Al Roker
Deborah Roberts Matt rise major Sam
linkler staff J Vargas Greg Morgan and
jelly roll and a big thank you to all
the men and women serving and
sacrificing for our fing We Salute You
we thank you we appreciate you have a
great day and it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home